oui on va regarder le taux de
vaccination au canada si vous voulez
bien ensemble pour rafraîchir la mémoire
à nos téléspectateurs
83 % des canadiens ont leurs premières
doses 70 % la deuxième dose
77 % et 28 % la troisième dose est ce
que vous pensez que ce taux est un bon
taux de vaccination y est ce qu il nous
permet justement d'aborder cette idée
qu'on amorce un tournant qu'on aura une
nouvelle approche avec avec cette
pandémie madame les moeurs bien écouter
le taux de vaccination est certainement
très bon puisqu'on se situe parmi les
meilleurs maintenant il faut aller plus
loin parce que l'immunité collective
on ne peut l'avoir que par la
vaccination ou l'infection et comme on a
déjà entendu mieux vaut de loin avoir le
vaccin que l'infection est donc il faut
vraiment doublé de d'efforts là pour
vacciner tout le monde incluant les
enfants et là-dessus j'aimerais
peut-être juste rajouter que ce qui a
fait ce qui fait peur ou aux parents
pour les enfants de moins de 12 ans et
d'une part la myocardite comme comme on
a entendu et d'autre part bon le fait
que ce soit un vaccin arn moi je
voudrais vous dire que pour les
myocardite les routes le risque de
d'avoir une myocardite si on est infecté
et de sept à dix fois plus élevé que si
on a le vaccin donc il ya déjà ça la
deuxième chose c'est que la rn et on l'a
vu dans le reportage c'est vraiment une
molécule qui est très instable et à
partir du moment où elle est dans la
cellule et qu'elle a produit la protéine
elle va être dégradée donc elle
disparaît a très rapidement alors moi
j'aimerais juste vraiment encouragée et
les adultes et les enfants à être
vaccinés et de travail a pas de vaccins
quand il ya des informations ni encore
un bout de chemin à faire de ce côté là
même du côté de la recherche de nouveaux
vaccins
oui tout à fait alors d'abord il faut
dire qu'au canada on mettrait bien vécu
signer là peut-être où le bât a blessé
un peu ça a été la vitesse
d'administration en ce qui concerne la
troisième dose surtout peut-être plus au
québec que dans certains autres
provinces mais on s'adapte c'était
vaccin à rl c'est comme un gâteau ou on
peut modifier la recette très très
rapidement et il suffit de modifier un
petit peu la recette pour avoir la
nouvelle variante la nouvelle version
améliorée du gâteau et comme on l'a bien
dit dans le reportage vous savez les
vaccins à rnc mieux d'attraper un vaccin
arn avec un tout petit morceau des
reines du virus que le virus au complet
parce que là vous allez avoir beaucoup
des reines et toutes les formes d'art et
reines du virus donc la vaccination ce
que ça a fait il faut pas oublier et à
peu près 9 9 milliards 700 millions de
doses de vaccins à date qui ont été
donnés dans le monde évidemment c'est
pas tous des vaccins rn certains sont
beaucoup moins efficaces en chine et en
inde mais ce qu'il faut se rappeler ce
que jamais dans l'histoire de l'humanité
on a donné autant de vaccins aussi
rapidement à autant de monde et à autant
de groupes vous savez des fois des
vaccins dans nos enfants aux personnes
âgées aux gens et mino supprimés là on
les a donné à tout le monde et donc on a
pu évaluer la sécurité du vaccin sur des
milliards de personnes dans tous les
groupes d'âge partout sur la planète les
hommes les femmes les plus jeunes et
plus vieux et je vous dirai toutes les
études pointent dans la même direction
les avantages de la vaccination
l'emportent très nettement sur je vous
dirais les problèmes potentiels
d'ailleurs on le voit malheureusement ce
qu'on voit actuellement de plus en plus
c'est des gens non vaccinés relativement
jeune et qu'on voit très malades parfois
aux soins intensifs on en discutera
probablement et on pourra discuter de
escaut micro est vraiment d'ailleurs
moins sévère que le reste parce que ça
affecte des gens non vaccinés on voit
encore des maladies sévères
oui docteur quoi donc en tant que
pédiatre est ce que vous avez vu des cas
de très jeunes enfants très malades ya
eu des cas anecdotiques ont été
rapportés dans le new york times il ya
pas tellement longtemps de médecins qui
disait écouter
de très jeunes patients beaucoup plus
qu'avant et on s'inquiète alors c'est
anecdotique n'est pas une série d'études
là dessus mais quelle est votre
réflexion à ce sujet là je vous dirais
qu un peu comme les autres virus
respiratoires le très jeunes enfants
âgés de moins de six mois en particulier
qui est exposée soit par la fratrie pour
les pare boue par les parents qui ne
sont pas vaccinés qui développe une
qu'ovide de façon précoce peut être
relativement malades avec problèmes
respiratoires intubation soins intensifs
donc c'est vraiment cette population là
chez les enfants qui est le plus à
risque de développer des complications
respiratoires d'où l'importance de
vacciner les mamans quand elles sont
enceintes mais aussi d'essayer de
limiter la transmission intrafamiliale
quand on a des plus grands frères et
soeurs qui vont à l'école pareil parce
que par exemple qui peuvent être
vaccinés et ensuite limiter la
transmission intrafamiliale et on sait
qu'il ya un essai clinique phase au bio
ntech justement avec les enfants de
moins de cinq ans et on s'est rendu
compte que le vaccin ne portait pas de
protection supplémentaire n'augmentez
pas les anticorps protecteurs qu'est ce
que ça veut dire c'est ce que ça veut
dire que peut-être ce vaccin va ne
pourrait pas fonctionner auprès des tout
petits ou les prochaines recherches
pourraient aboutir à quelque chose de
plus positif d'après vous ou si le
nombre de doses nécessaires parce qu'on
se rappellera que quand on compare le
nombre de doses nécessaires chez un très
jeune enfant par rapport à un plus vieux
ça prend parfois plus de vaccins dans la
dose primaire est-ce que ça va être le
dosage qui ce qui sera différent c'est
pour ça qu'on ne peut pas conclure sur
ces résultats là tant et aussi longtemps
qu'on ne les avait pas vus et quand on
entend le ms déclaré qu'il faut faire
attention et a fait l'immense nous met
en garde contre
la tentation de comparer ce qui se passe
actuellement un même dans le fond cette
pandémie là ce n'est qu'un rhume
si on bat réaction à ça parce qu'il ya
bien des gens qui vont dire à quoi bon
faire vacciner si je suis heureux de
toute façon à quoi bon faire vacciner
même les verts les vaccinés sont malades
de quoi trembler moi je peux vous dire
que j'étais à l'hôpital aujourd'hui l'un
puis j'ai vu trois de mes patients qui
étaient relativement immuno supprimer
qui sont rentrés à l'hôpital pour une
autre raison testés négatifs à l'entrée
deux jours plus tard artistes positif et
24 heures après ils étaient rendus aux
soins intensifs alors pour ceux qui
pensent que c'est au micro c'est juste
un rhume c'est faux il faut vraiment
s'enlever cette vidéo micron peut causer
une maladie aussi grave que delta et ça
va être particulièrement vrai chez les
non vaccinés
particulièrement vrai chez les immuno
compromis puis j'aimerais que ce que les
gens pensent que dise et quoi que ça
veut dire être quelqu'un qui était minot
compromis c'est des gens que vous
connaissez c'est une soeur qu'il ya un
cancer du simple que de chimiothérapie
c'est un oncle qu'un cancer du pancréas
puis qui il suit des traitements depuis
un bon moment c'est quelqu'un qui est
vih et puis il ya des cd4 très bas on
connaît tous des gens dans nos
entourages ces gens là il faut les
protéger et puis si c'est pas une
motivation personnelle qui va faire en
sorte que les gens vont aller chercher
leur troisième dose je pense qu'il faut
penser à ces gens là qui vont être les
premières victimes finalement de cette
vague là très rapidement dr couach une
question de l'ena chabot ou chabot est
ce qu il ya de la coved longue chez les
enfants en fait quand on regarde les
études jusqu'à maintenant par départ des
sondages où il manque en fait aux
enfants aux parents est ce que votre
enfant a eu perte de concentration
fatigue tout prolongé tout on s'il ya
quelque chose c'est autour de 2 à 4% ce
qui est intéressant par contre c'est
quand on compare ça à une population
témoin qui n'a pas fait la queue vide
les pourcentages rapportés sont à peu
près similaires donc ça se demander si
la copie de l'ong existe parce que ça
c'est pas clair chez les enfants laissés
symptômes là pourrait être due au
confinement l'école à la maison et à
tout le reste donc il n'ya pas de n'y a
pas d'évidence clair que chez le jeune
enfant il ya effectivement une copie de
longues mais là tu merci beaucoup
docteur couach